لذلك نريدهم أن يكونوا متساوين
الأجور والطبقة العاملة لدي
أكثر بقليل من
الصوت يستحق ذلك لأن الحقيقة هي أن
القطاعات متخلفة عن الركب
تحت ما هو التضخم و
زيادة الأسعار على جميع المنتجات
نعم نعم لمعرفة الأجور ما أنت عليه
الآن الحصول على راتب
الحد الأدنى لا يصل إليك مقابل تكلفة
الحياة هناك الآن هذا ما نحن عليه
مدعيا أنه هو نفسه بعد قليل
الظروف
يرتفع الاستهلاك بنسبة 10٪ وترتفع الأجور
1٪ تعني أن كتلة
العمال يفقدون القوة
شراء طريقة واحدة للمسيرات
أجبرنا على القيام به كل يوم
أفقر
[موسيقى]
الوضع الحالي هو أننا في
شهر نوفمبر وزيادة الراتب
3.5٪ وهو بالمناسبة مصادفة اليوم
تجلى لنا هنا والبريد
جمعت للغد ليدفع لنا في
الشهر 11 من 12 شهرًا الذي يحتوي على هذا العام
إنه عار
[موسيقى]
أسوأ شيء هو أن هناك أقلية لكل منهما
اليوم يبدو أكثر ثراءً لكوستا دي
أولئك منا الموجودين هنا كل يوم
أفقر
نحن في الأساس ما نحن عليه
سؤال الرؤساء هو هذا في الكل
الاتفاقات الجماعية ويمكن أن يكون
يدعو سببًا لمراجعة ذلك
تأكد من أن جميع العمال
هذه الدولة
إيه من الواضح أنه راتب لا
تخسر سوف تشتري بسبب
من الواضح التضخم الحالي
يقترب من 12٪ في إسبانيا وأولئك الذين
لقد نشأنا في الاتفاقيات بالكاد
2٪. عندما قمنا بالفعل بسحب أكثر من واحد
ستة ونصف العام الماضي
أفترض أنه من الناحية العملية
فترة سنتين أو ثلاث سنوات بشكل أساسي
فقدنا 30٪ من رواتبنا
في تلك القوة الشرائية
[تصفيق]